[Música]
mi nombre es catalina soy del mundo
no soy lo que parecía no
porque esta ropa podría generar una
atención incómoda por eso quiero
contarles que fue un regalo me lo regaló
mohamed un español que se convierte al
islam y se mudó de barcelona a qatar
donde lo conocí me enseñe mucho de la
cultura islámica me mostró la mezquita
en detalle y pienso que me habrá visto
tan entusiasmada que decidió regalarme
una valla cuando salí de ahí recuerdo
haber sido la única persona de un grupo
enorme que se iba con una valla de
regalo
decidí ponerme la
y caminar muchas cuadras
en el anonimato de esta túnica negra yo
era una qatarí más sin prejuicios y con
amor este o todo atuendo que ven acá se
lo compré una mujer en sir lanka algunos
conoce esta hermosa isla que marcopolo
alguna vez llamó la flor de la india los
antiguos marinos la llamaban ser en deep
que significa algo así como hallazgo
afortunado si la ncaa es un país con
forma de lágrima abajo de la india donde
conocí una mujer que me invitó un test
cuando entré a su tienda había salir por
todas partes saco el color que más me
gustaba me paró delante un espejo y en
cuestión de segundos consiguió que siete
metros de tela me quedaran tan lindos
como a todas ellas descubrió entonces
que mohamed y ella tenían algo en común
amaban lo que hacían y me transmitían
ese amor habían logrado que yo también
me enamore de ellos de sus países de su
cultura de sus historias aunque a decir
verdad mis primeras experiencias con el
amor habían sido mucho antes
cuando yo tenía seis años recuerdo que
por ese momento un violador serial era
el centro de la agenda mediática solía
atacar mujeres cerca de la zona de mi
colegio estaban pasando la noticia en la
radio y yo estaba con mi papá estábamos
solos
y recuerda o no escuchado decir que
ojalá ese hombre se muriera
con toda la inocencia de un niño yo le
dije papá nadie merece morir lo que me
impactó no fue que mi papá dijera eso
fue la reacción que tuvo después esa
reacción de serendipia pero interno paró
el auto en costado me miró fijo y con
lágrimas en los ojos me dijo catalina
tienes razón lo que ese hombre necesita
es más amor por eso hoy vamos a rezar
por él y vamos a mandarle mucho amor
yo le agradezco toda la vida a mi papá
por no contradecir me por redimirse y
enseñarme que el mundo no es un lugar
malo que todo es cuestión de amor pero
como la vida circular y te envuelve y te
desenvuelve como un sari resultó que
años más tarde
que necesitaríamos en las noticias
éramos nosotros despidiendo al primer
hombre asesinado en un barrio cerrado mi
abuelo mi papá estaba destrozado y yo le
dije que ojalá ese hombre se muriera con
toda la inocencia
de mi papá en ese momento me miró fijo y
me dijo no catalina lo que ese hombre
necesita es más amor por eso hoy vamos a
rezar por la persona que mató a tu
abuelo y vamos a mandarle mucho amor a
partir de ahí empecé a catalogar el
mundo en dos tipos de acciones me decía
a mí misma o todo lo que una persona
hace es una expresión de amor o todo lo
que una persona hace es una petición de
amor no hay otra variable y aunque todo
suene color de rosa ver el mundo de este
modo
requiere un valor inmenso porque te van
a decir que estás loco y que si crees en
el amor no te va a ir bien cuando yo era
chica quería ser médica pediatra no fui
médica porque eso me llevaría muchos
años de estudio en los que yo quería
también viajar y conocer el mundo y
paradójicamente viajando descubrí que
amar era una manera de salvar el mundo
por eso el año pasado me fui a hacer un
voluntariado un orfanato muy chiquitito
en el medio de pequeña me contacte por
facebook con un chico que pedía
voluntarios para su proyecto y me
embarqué en el viaje más transformador
de mi vida las respuestas que recibí
cuando dije que me iba a ir sola áfrica
son las que ya conocen vos estás loca
puede matarte puedes agarrar una
enfermedad las respuestas nunca fueron
amables a lo que yo respondí a twitter
de todas esas personas ninguna me dijo
que sí y es cierto me podría haber
muerto pero también me puedo morir en
buenos aires en un barrio cerrado de mi
perspectiva morir no es un acto ligado a
la ubicación geográfica aunque había
comprobado que para mucha gente si lo
era claro como tengo suerte estoy viva
me empecé a dar cuenta que áfrica era la
metáfora perfecta para que todo lo que
yo pensaba de la vida todos tenemos una
áfrica un lugar desconocido al que le
tenemos mucho miedo una versión de
nosotros mismos que no nos animamos a
transitar una parte del mundo que nos
pide más amor y salir de nuestra zona
cómoda para recorrer ese lugar puede ser
la decisión más valiente que hayamos
tomado en nuestra vida claro pero cuando
llegas a un lugar del que solo con el
nombre y que te vas a morir se empieza a
complicar cuando por fin llegue a kenia
empecé a notar la dimensión que estaba
tomando mi vida era la dimensión del
mundo que me resonaba adentro
áfrica para mí era un mundo aparte me
esperaba un hombre que supuestamente
tenía que reconocer entre un millón de
personas amontonadas que para mí eran
todas iguales no sabía cómo hacerlo me
quedé parada yo era la única persona de
tez blanca así que lo más probable es
que él me encontrara primero a mí aunque
estuviéramos a kilómetros de distancia y
así fue se me acercó más de uno
gritando ofreciéndome en cosas tocando
me el pelo todo muy raro hasta que por
fin apareció el indicado que en un
inglés bastante raro me dijo catalina y
ahí supe que en ese tenía que confiar
sí bastante iluso lo mío pero no no
tenía muchas más opciones así que
durante las siguientes tres horas estuve
sentada en la parte de atrás de un auto
con dos kenianos adelante que
prácticamente no me dirigieron la
palabra entre ellos hablaron su ágil y
todo el viaje y mientras tanto yo me
imaginaba la cantidad de cosas que
podrían estar diciendo mientras pensaba
también
todas las formas posibles de tirarme del
auto en el caso de que esas cosas fueran
ciertas pero si no lo hice si no me tiré
el auto fue porque constantemente me
recordaba a mí misma las creencias que
me habían llevado y de repente el auto
empezó a adentrarse en una calle muy muy
angosta que desembocaba en un portón
grande con dos masajes con lanza en la
entrada su paciencia cierta que ese
portón era la puerta hacia el áfrica que
llevaba dentro como por impulso me bajé
el auto mientras abrían el portón y lo
único que pude ver fue más de 15 chicos
de todas las edades viviendo me
encuentro gritando mi nombre casi no
podía avanzar tenía una avalancha de
amor encima y ese era uno de los
encuentros más genuinos que había tenido
hasta entonces en el mes y medio
siguiente llegué a conocer a cada uno de
esos chicos en detalle conocí sus
historias de corazón sus alegrías sus
tristezas todo lo que hacía que fueran
ellos
yo lo sanara tanto como a mí misma
comprendí entonces que yo no había
tenido suerte de estar viva
haya tenido suerte de conocerlos de ser
amada por ellos y amarlos tanto y la
suerte no te toca vos la elegís y yo
había elegido creer en el amor por sobre
todas las cosas había elegido a hablar
ese idioma y por eso siempre lo obtuve
de vuelta y empecé a hablar ese idioma
mucho antes de irme de viaje y lo sigo
hablando aún hoy y cuando hablo de amor
y de áfrica no puedo no hablar de la
isla musulmana del amor más cerca de
somalia que pequeña donde ya nadie va
porque de vez en cuando el grupo
terrorista al shabab a su historia
cada vez más seguido la muera como un
mundo aparte dentro de un mundo aparte
por lo tanto sí que ya era peligroso la
muera la muerte segura pero esa altura
nadie me podría convencer de no ir y me
termine enamorando del amor y su gente
no tengo palabras para explicar todo lo
que aprendí en esta isla acá fue donde
conocí a omar nos hicimos grandes amigos
y justo al principio de esa amistad me
acuerdo que le pregunté why you from the
donde sos como cualquier persona que se
va a convertir en tu amigo y su
respuesta me hizo más que verificar
porque debía hacerlo me miró anonadado
como si yo estuviera haciendo una
pregunta tan obvia como cuántos dedos
tengo y sin lugar a dudas me contestó
hay forma en manos tomar
omar tenía razón mi pregunta era obvia
yo también venía del útero de mi madre y
entre él y yo no había ninguna
diferencia sustancial para ayudar a los
niños de áfrica no necesitaba venir
con toneladas de agua
necesitaba escucharlos comprenderlos sus
problemas existenciales eran iguales que
los míos
todos sufríamos y nos alegrábamos por
las mismas cosas apariencia
éramos totalmente diferentes pero en el
corazón éramos totalmente iguales
ellos eran parte de mi identidad
ellos eran mi familia y por eso cuando
me preguntan de dónde soy yo contexto
que soy de todos lados porque me
considero una ciudadana del mundo y los
ciudadanos del mundo
escribimos nuestra propia versión del
planeta y para aprenderla salimos de
nosotros mismos
nos sentimos responsables por la
totalidad del mundo no solo por una
parte los ciudadanos del mundo contamos
historias basadas en afinidades y no en
diferencias somos capaces de mirar un
mapa y recordar cómo fuimos
transformados
por las personas que conocimos las cosas
que vimos
y los lugares en los que estuvimos
y sabemos que la verdadera
transformación del mundo no proviene de
lo que estemos haciendo sino de la
conciencia con la que lo hagamos y el
amor es la conciencia más elevada bajo
la cual un ser humano puede actuar
porque transforma incluso
los prejuicios más profundos
y a mí me gusta pensar
con
da igual cuántas veces
publicamos en nuestro muro que rezamos
por parís new york o barcelona si en
nuestras cabezas seguimos haciendo la
guerra si cada vez que alguien les
pregunte
o les diga que se va a ir a áfrica o que
se quiere ir a áfrica y ustedes le digan
que se va a morir
me gusta pensar que esa ciudadanía
existe
y que es como un pasaporte que uno lleva
inscripto en el alma que dice nací en el
mundo
me considero humana
mi partido político son la libertad y el
respeto y mi única religión es el amor
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]